the head coach of the Michigan Wolverine
basketball program John Beall on back
here on the Rich Eisen show how are you
coach Hybrid great they're great to be
on your show and always great to have
you here where's the net right now that
you cut down where's that look oh I
think it was I think it was actually
around my Secretary's next day to
surprise it's right in my office just
sort of waiting to be placed over this
big trophy that we have we got to buy
after last year and this is we gotta buy
some new toys trophy cases to fit these
things then it's a great problem they
have well I thought when you're saying
by you meant the week that you've got a
chill out now I mean it does seem like
you have a bye week right now how how do
you think this is going to affect things
now that you're gonna pass it around and
worry I've been I've been through it
before when I was at Canisius in
Richmond and then you know you final
Wichita State when they went back when
they're in the Missouri Valley Gonzaga
they've all done well in the tournaments
I think a lot is made of this and so
what we're trying to do is have a these
little two day camps with a day off we'd
really in it's really important I think
that we get their heart rates up and we
get them playing game experience but
it's also you don't want to overdo it
this week so we had a good practice
yesterday and but it was things rich
that we would do in October you know
getting a stat slide steps you know just
working on just simple passing
everything that that we emphasize all
year long but you can't ever say you
can't do it too much in in the practices
when you had such a busy schedule so and
then we're gonna have a scrimmage Friday
with just inter-squad scrimmage of our
two teams playing with breasts and
everything and and try to replicate a
game the best we could and then all of a
sudden its election Sunday and and
everything's back to normal
John Beilein here on the Rich Eisen show
so so much being discussed about
one-and-done players in in NCAA
basketball do you avoid them do you try
to get them I mean what is your your
philosophy on players that you know
would be on Ann Arbor campus for only
one year if they play for you know we're
definitely not avoiding it but we're not
gonna we're not going to say we can we
we need them to win or if a kid if a
one-and-done player like Mitch McGary
back in 13 was once seen as a
one-and-done player but he wanted to go
to Michigan and it's like if the guy is
is is you know running through the doors
to come to Michigan right then we are
we're all in but if he is if he
announces his list of 12 and we're one
of them we're not going to recruit them
you know it's it's it's got to be
something that is there's got to be
unique interest in him and and we've
we've gone down the road with a few
really good players I'm oh bombuh
right jaylen brown where we will
probably finish second or third in some
of those situations and so but they had
unique interests in Michigan so if we
get if we get them that's great if we
don't there's a lot of ways to win and
we if you have great for your players
that are you know if you have a whole
bunch of muhammad ali abdul rahman and
duncan robinson's you know Jordan
Morgan's and some of these guys that did
not go pro early you can still win
there's no question about that but you
don't feel pressure to try and keep up
with the one-and-done Joneses coach
absolutely not no no no why not because
it seems like so many people would when
they're in the position but maybe
somebody should do some research right
now on the one-and-done guys and and how
successful the college play the couch
programs they are come from it seems to
me that there's been a lot of coaches
fire the last couple years who had one
and dones and it is a it's a difficult
it's a slippery slope of when that the
kid is and when I'm not faulting the
young man you got he's got millions of
dollars waiting for him and you're
telling he's got to go to study hall and
he needs to he needs to work on his left
hand you know and he needs to throw his
passes on time on target when everybody
else may be saying anything listen you
just don't get injured because you're a
you're a lottery pick and you've got
millions of dollars coming for you
that's a difficult thing it's got to be
unique it
can handle both and nothing there's
nothing wrong with with people who want
to recruit that athlete that's fine we
just want the right one if it comes to
that John Beilein of the University of
Michigan here on the Rich Eisen show how
do you know what the right one is what
it looked what that kid looks like
certainly since you have a rule that you
it's easy to find out rich if he has a
unique interest in Michigan right as you
know Michigan's not going to be for
everybody and if he's got a unique
interest it's easy and then then you get
to decide ok is that that the position
we need right it might not be the
position we need and you said you just
move on so there's this is you're not
here's here's the key and I I'm sure you
remember Rudy Tomjanovich sir
Rudy told me this a long time ago you
are not a massing talent you are
building the team and so you know that
that's how great teams are made so we're
not looking for just Talent we want guys
who who can make us a better team and it
seems every year the team improves
immeasurably from when you first get
them after summer to right now
tournament time what is your secret
sauce coach work these guys get coached
up and our tournament ready and tested
for kids who might not have even been
through it before
what what is your secret sauce coach
well it's just we try to really
prioritize and it's not a secret it is I
think a lot of good coaches do the exact
same thing is that you you just tried it
to have a great emphasis on individual
development all year long you don't you
don't you don't spend your times all
exclusively on the other teams how to
balance plays and your plays you're
working with drivel legit with driven
with your eyes up you know like I said
throwing passes on time on target you
know all the little things defensively
that the techniques that you have to use
individually to make them better and if
you just stay with that so if we have to
day prep rich and it's two days before
we'll spend half an hour on the next
opponent will spend 90 minutes on
ourselves
and then the day before we'll probably
spend 30 30 minutes on ourselves and you
know an hour and 15 minutes on the
opponent so it is a good grad you Diskin
and lots of coaches do that we didn't we
didn't invent it we did invent anything
we're just trying to we borrow from
others and try to do the best we can
John Beilein of the University of
Michigan couple more minutes with him
here on the Rich Eisen show so much
being discussed about fixing college
basketball right now what do you think
needs fixing from your point of view
coach
oh man III think what's the easiest
thing that I think a lot of a lot of
coaches would agree on is the the whole
one-and-done I did it is it is a it's a
difficult thing for us all to to get
through III love the baseball rule rich
I love it I love it I think just that if
the kid really does not have unique
interest in going to to play in four
years of college or and and really get
an education and a college experience
that that that's okay that's perfectly
fine and there's got to be a way that
they can that they can still go to the
NBA or go to the G League and and then
begin their process of becoming a career
basketball player but there's a lot of
young men just like in baseball that
will say hey I'm gonna go to Michigan
I'm gonna go Stanford right I'm gonna go
to Vanderbilt I'm gonna go to one of
those schools North Carolina I'm gonna
go there and I'm gonna play baseball for
three years and let's see where I'm
going to be drafted I know I could go to
the minor leagues now in baseball but I
wanna i want experience college I want
to I want I know that I may not be able
play baseball as a career I and I want
to be ready for other things and and its
really an easy solution and I I don't
know if we'll go that way but that's my
that would be my personal recommendation
of what we do about that I think as far
as fixing college basketball it does not
need a big fix yeah most people are
doing it the right way
there's just apparently and when if all
these accusations are all true they're
apparently somewhat then aren't
but that's what's gonna make the news
you know that's why we have a 35 mile an
hour stop sign or a 15 mile hour speed
limit around a school because some
people are not going to honor what's
within the importance of slowing down in
school districts and or just you know
being cautious when they need to be
cautious and doing the right thing so
it's a it it's gonna get right we've
gone through these things again before
and it's going to get right it's it's
bigger than there it's it's going to be
much bigger than these problems one day
so you think the fix is or should come
from the NBA rather than from NCAA
headquarters in Indianapolis yeah yes in
some areas is powerlessness because the
NBA does control when a kids can go pro
and and so that is a that's a something
and I and the last the last few years
there's been incredible cooperation
between the NCAA and the NBA is we try
to move in that direction okay so what
do you think what are you thinking about
your seed and location I'm pounding the
table I want a two seed I don't care of
it don't care what about Detroit what
about what about the location would be
great to play there but but it would be
great it's great to be in the tournament
and just wherever wherever gives us the
best chance of winning and and we won't
know that until we play the games but
you can have it you can absolutely have
a be sent to the other side of the world
and have a great matchup for you it as
it turns out or you could be you could
go 40 miles around away and have the
worst matchup for you so as you know
that many of these games are all about
that that today there's so much parity
in the game they we could we could go
anywhere I really don't care I just want
to play and and just have these guys
just blown and plays keep playing till
said tell us some somebody tell us we
can't play anymore and play the best
basketball that we can play I saw they
represent rich the greatest university
in the world yeah you know that I know
that not many people appreciate that
though coach you know what I'm saying
take more than you think and I noticed
you put Moe vogner's headsets on he
wanted to play the German rap music for
you and you said you liked it is that is
that really it was really good it was
really good the beats were the same but
I don't know what that they were saying
but it was really good stuff it was
really good I I love music and this is
something I'm gonna have to put on my
playlist to get a few of those things
just to change things up well look I'm
speaking on behalf of the entire alumni
base this is great stuff
really love the way you go about your
business and the way that you coach kids
up it's just a delight to see and on
I'll have my seat belt buckled for for
next women looking forward to it alright
alright thanks rich very very much
appreciate your you're a great example
of a Michigan alum thank you for what
you do oh my gosh
right back at you thanks coach ATS John
Beilein on Twitter and his son is
killing it to the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience